[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
die Doktorarbeit der Ärztin Lydia von
den Hof hat folgenden Titel nicht
invasive Beatmung NEV mittels eines
kompakt-systems zur Behandlung
postoperativer hypoxämien im Aufwachraum
von der medizinischen Fakultät der
rheinisch fest fälischen Technischen
Hochschule Aachen zur Erlangung des
akademischen Grades einer Doktorin der
Medizin genehmigte Dissertation
vorgelegt von Lydia von den Hof geborene
Kolleg und am Ende steht ein
unglaublicher maßlos perfider Satz in
Kapitel 8 Danksagung schreibt sie
schließlich danke ich ganz besonders
meinem Ehemann für die unerschöpfliche
Geduld und Motivation
heißt Hermann von den Hof ein paar Tage
vor Abgabe ihrer Promotionsarbeit da hat
sie ihn umgebracht sie rammte dem
herzkranken Mann eine Morphin Spritze in
den Oberschenkel durch seine Blutbahn
strömte die 20-fach tödliche Menge des
Schmerzmittels
[Musik]
und damit herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge von Tatort Deutschland mein
Name ist Mirko Kasimir und ich bin Toni
Heyer hallo in ihrem Lebenslauf der zu
Dr Arbeit gehört schreibt die Ärztin
Lydia von den Hof wahrheitsgemäß
Familienstand verwitwett mit dem Mord an
ihrem Mann endet eine absolut
ungewöhnliche Lebensgeschichte und wie
so oft war die spätere Täterin früher
auch ein Opfer
Lydia von den hoff wird als Lydia Collie
am 17 dezember 1975 in Stockach in
Baden-Württemberg geboren
bis ans Ufer des Bodensees sind es
weniger als 7 km heile Welt sagen die
die Mal dort waren und kennen wir nicht
sagen die die man dort heute nach Lydia
fragt
im 20 km entfernten Überlingen besucht
sie die Grundschule von 1985 bis 1991
die Hauptschule in Stockach in den drei
Hauptschulen der Stadt kann sich niemand
an eine Lydia erinnern die
Familienverhältnisse sind schwierig ihre
Eltern sind fanatische Anhänger der
Zeugen Jehovas macht der frühen
Scheidung da ist Lydia erst drei Jahre
alt da wächst sie erstmal bei der
strengen Mutter auf die zieht aus
Geldnot immer wieder von einer Stadt in
die nächste
Lydia erlebt ständig neue Kindergärten
und Tagesmütter auch in der Schulzeit
setzt sich dieses Nomadenleben der
Mutter fort mittlerweile hat die Mutter
mit einem neuen Partner zwei Kinder
Lydia soll sich oft um die
Halbgeschwister kümmern sie hat keine
Freunde und fühlt sich nirgends
zugehörig im Alter von etwa 12 Jahren
flüchtet sich das Mädchen zum Vater und
dessen neuer Frau auch diese beiden sind
glühende Anhänger der Zeugen Jehovas in
dieser Familie hier gibt es einen
älteren Stiefbruder er fotografiert
Lydia nackt und missbraucht sie also
alles in allem kann man wirklich sagen
ein beschissener Staat ins Leben für
Lydia und Lydia die Haut voll aus der
Kurve sie rennt von zu Hause weg Trump
nach Stuttgart und spritzt dort zum
ersten Mal Heroin sie kommt in die
Kinder und Jugendpsychiatrie danach
kehrt Lydia zurück zum Vater sie geht
kaum noch zur Schule immer wieder haut
sie ab nach Stuttgart oder Berlin später
flüchtet sie auch aus dem betreuten
Wohnheim in Konstanz in dem sie
untergekommen ist mit 17 hat sie ihren
ersten Freund er zeigt ihr wie man
Gitarre spielt sie leben in einem
Bauwagen machen Musik kiffen ein kurzes
Glück dann nimmt sie wieder Heroin mit
ihrem Freund sieht sie nach Aachen
sie versucht sich als Straßenmusikerin
aber schließlich geht sie dann auf den
Strich einfach weil das mehr Geld bringt
über diese Zeit sagt sie später die
Männer seien über sie hergefallen wie
die Wölfe sie habe sich nur noch als ein
Stück Fleisch empfunden wenn man das
erlebt hat da stirbt man innerlich und
wirkt es fast wie eine Wendung aus einem
kitsch-film aller Pretty Woman als Lydia
Hermann kennenlernt da ist sie 20 und
geht immer noch anschaffen hermann ist
70 und ihr freier er hat einen Sohn und
ist von seiner Exfrau getrennt aus der
Geschäftsbeziehung wird ein persönliches
Verhältnis Hermann nimmt die
Drogensüchtige Prostituierte ohne
Schulabschluss und Perspektive bei sich
auf die beiden wohnen im Aachener
Stadtteil Haren in einem
Mehrfamilienhaus solange sie noch auf
Heroin ist hilft er manchmal dabei den
Stoff zu besorgen aber er drängt sie zum
Aufhören und über sagt Lydia schließlich
davon bei einem Methadonprogramm
mitzumachen als sie clean ist geht sie
auf die Volkshochschule Aachen dort
macht sie 1999 den Hauptschulabschluss
was für ein Erfolg nach all den Jahren
in der Gosse und Lydia reicht das noch
nicht sie macht weiter die
abentealschule schließt sie 2001 mit der
Fachhochschulreife ab das Abendgymnasium
2002 mit der allgemeinen Hochschulreife
dem Abitur nur drei Jahre nachdem sie
ohne Schulabschluss durchs Leben
gerettet ist mittlerweile haben sich
auch die Nachbarn an das schrägepaar
gewöhnt da ist der kahle Rentner der mal
lebensmittelkaufmann war und an seiner
Seite eine lebendige attraktive Ex
Sexarbeiterin und die möchte auch
studieren
die beiden fahren gerne gemeinsam zum
Camping nach Holland wenn sie das machen
übernimmt eine Nachbarin den
blumendienst im Oktober 2003 schreibt
sich Lydia an der Technischen Hochschule
Aachen im fachmedizin ein fünf Jahre
später am 18 August 2008 beginnt die
Medizinstudentin an der Uniklinik ihr
praktisches Jahr als Ärztin erst in der
Chirurgie dann in der Inneren Abteilung
zum Schluss in der Anästhesiologie
im Januar 2010 ist sie approbierte
Ärztin im Februar heiratet Sie Hermann
hier könnte der kitsch-film jetzt enden
die wundersame Rettung der missbrauchten
lydia hat sie von der Straße weggebracht
von der Prostitution und jetzt spritzt
sie sich keine Betäubungsmittel mehr in
den Arm sondern betäubt Patienten als
Narkoseärztin und sie ist schon viele
viele Jahre mit ihrem Hermann zusammen
aber die Welt ist auch jetzt nicht
perfekt
lydia ist mit Hermann nicht glücklich
und sucht über ein Flirtportal Partner
im Oktober lernt sie wie gewünscht einen
anderen Mann kennen sie trifft sich mit
Walter g er ist deutlich jünger als
Hermann naja also Walter ist auch schon
66 Jahre alt aber immerhin erst
pensionierte Lehrer für Französisch und
Musik und kommt aus dem Schwarzwald als
ich Lydia um einen Job an der Uniklinik
Ulm bewirbt und dort am 16 februar 2011
sogar ein Vorstellungsgespräch hat Bucht
weiter ihr ein Zimmer im Gästehaus
Gisela dort haben sie Sex Hermann weiß
irgendwann von dieser Liebschaft und
reagiert zornig und gekränkt er sperrt
Lydia den Zugang zu allen konnten er
schließt ihr Fahrrad weg und im Februar
2011 wird aus der Pretty Woman
Geschichte ein mörderischer Thriller als
Lydia am 17 februar von der Reise nach
Ulm zurückkehrt will Hermann sie zur
Rede stellen
am 19 februar 2011 wird Lydia den Notruf
in ihrem gemeinsamen Haus liege ihr Mann
Hermann leblos auf dem
wohnzimmerfußboden als die
Rettungssanitäter und ein Notarzt
eintreffen können Sie nur noch den Tod
des Mannes feststellen bei einem
85-jährigen der sowieso schon
Herzprobleme hatte da macht das erstmal
niemanden misstrauisch aber auf den
zweiten Blick bemerkt der Notarzt eine
kleine Wunde daraufhin empfiehlt er eine
Obduktion die Wunde Spuren von Morphinen
im Blut Beweise im Haus es dauert nicht
lange bis Lydia als mordverdächtig gilt
und festgenommen wird außerdem soll sie
immerhin 100.000 € haben aber gegenüber
der Polizei schweigt Lydia und später
auch vor Gericht am 7 dezember 2011
beginnt vor dem schulgericht Aachen der
Mordprozess gegen Lydia von den Hof die
Verteidigung übernimmt der Kölner
Staranwalt Reinhard Birkenstock der hat
schon viele Prominente vertreten und
auch schwierige Fälle übernommen und
auch hier gibt er sich alle Mühe er baut
Lydia Schweigen in seine Strategie ein
und bietet dem Gericht eine Alternative
todestheorie nach der anderen Hermann
könne an Altersschwäche gestorben sein
er habe vielleicht aus Verlustangst
selber Morphium genommen um sich
umzubringen
dass er eine Überdosis intus hatte stets
zwar fest aber nicht wer sie ihm
verabreicht hat am 30 April 2012
überrascht Lydia das Gericht und auch
ihren prominenten Anwalt plötzlich
entschließt sie sich doch noch zu reden
und zu gestehen ja sie habe ihren Mann
getötet sie sagt er sei kontrollierend
und beherrschend gewesen und in der Tat
macht da sei die Situation dann
eskaliert Lydia schildert im Gericht wie
die Spannungen in der Ehe zunahmen
aber kennenlernte wie verletzt und
trotzig Haman darauf reagierte trotzdem
erzählt sie konnte sie sich einfach
nicht von ihm trennen lieber habe sie
noch viele und andere Tabletten
eingenommen um sich selbst Tag für Tag
unter Kontrolle zu bringen am Abend des
18 Februar so erzählt es Lydia da sei
alles zwischen den beiden eskaliert
beide seien irgendwann betrunken gewesen
Hermann habe sie ins Gesicht geschlagen
und ihr alles mögliche angedroht ohne
mich wärst du gar nichts ich habe dich
von der Straße geholt wenn du mich
verlässt schicke ich dich wieder in die
Gosse du wirst wieder eine
Drogenabhängige Straßen und die zu den
Pennern gehört ich sorge dafür dass sie
die Zulassung erzogen wird du kannst nie
wieder als Ärztin arbeiten
Lydia sagt vor Gericht sie sei in die
Küche gerannt um sich selber eine
Spritze mit Morphium zu verabreichen
Hermann habe währenddessen immer
weitergeschrieben Lydia zieht die
Spritze immer weiter auf saugt immer
mehr aus der ampele und dann durchfährt
sie der tödliche forstsatz sie rennt
zurück zu Hermann und rammt ihm die
Nadel ins Bein drückt ab bis alles in
seinem Körper ist
unsere Kollegen Sascha Baumann und
Holger karkeck haben die Geschichte von
Lydia im Jahr 2012 sehr gut und
ausführlich für die BILD am SONNTAG
aufgeschrieben sie lesenswert aus dieser
Zeit ist aber auch der Artikel der
Spiegel Gerichtsreporterin Gisela
Friedrichson sie hat mit ihrer
langjährigen Erfahrung
auseinandergenommen was davor Gericht
ablief und das war offenbar nicht so gut
für Lydia seit ihrer Festnahme hat sie
geschwiegen eine psychiatrische
Gutachterin musste über Lydia urteilen
obwohl sie kein Wort sprach ihr
dramatisches Geständnis vor Gericht das
kommt erst als der Prozess schon in die
Verlängerung gegangen ist ihr
Verteidiger Birkenstock ist nicht darauf
eingestellt also den Mord quasi als
notretter zu stellen er sagt später wenn
Lydia von den Hof gleich nach der
Festnahme gesagt hätte was an ihn am
Abend passiert ist und wenn sie es so
geschildert hätte wie am Ende der
Hauptverhandlung dann wäre sie
vermutlich mit einer Verurteilung wegen
Totschlags im minder schweren Fall davon
gekommen
kurz gesagt hat Lydia also den richtigen
Zeitpunkt verpasst sich als Opfer
darzustellen also als die Frau die immer
weckt in tiefster Verzweiflung ihren
Mann tötete der Vorsitzende Richter Gerd
Nohl verurteilt Lydia zu lebenslange
Haft stellt aber immerhin keine
besondere Schwere der Schuld fest in
seiner Urteilsbegründung sagt er sie
habe in wenigen Sekunden nicht nur das
Leben ihres Mannes sondern auch all das
was sie sich bis dahin in
anerkennenswerter Weise erarbeitet habe
zerstört
und das stimmt denn Lydia von den Hof
kann bei guter Führung zwar
wahrscheinlich bald aus dem Gefängnis
entlassen werden aber sie wird wegen der
Entziehung der sogenannten Approbation
nie wieder als Ärztin arbeiten dürfen
und ich finde das ist hier so ein Fall
das ist immer gar nicht so leicht
darüber irgendwie zu urteilen weil auf
der einen Seite sie hat als Kind in
ihrer jugendtile schreckliche Sachen
erlebt und auch durchgemacht und da sind
mit Sicherheit auch viele Traumata
vorhanden
sie da aber dafür ein Schutz zu nehmen
das ist halt aber auch zu faul weil wir
haben das ja auch schon öfter gehabt
dass das eben unglückliche Beziehungen
sind und auch durch frühere schlimme
Erfahrungen da der Mut fehlt sich
rauszulösen ich sage jetzt mal auf die
normale Art und Weise also durch
Kommunikation und einfach auch diese
scheiß Phase mal durchleben und sie hat
das nicht aufgearbeitet die schlimmen
Sachen die ihr passiert sind und sagt
dann vor Gericht aus Verzweiflung habe
sie immer man getötet und ich meine es
ist verständlich dass wenn er rausfindet
dass sie ihn betrügt dass er verletzt
ist die konnten Schwert vielleicht auch
ein bisschen kindisch reagiert aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist das kein Grund zu
sagen ich kann mich nicht von diesen
Mann anders treffen als ihn zu töten
ja man könnte auch sagen es ist halt
eine Beziehung die über die Zeit um es
vielleicht ein bisschen salopp
formuliert aus dem Ruder gelaufen ist
auf der einen Seite er den die
Verlustangst dazu treibt seine deutliche
jüngere Ehefrau immer mehr einzuenken
und auf der anderen Seite sie die
dankbar war für die Dinge die ihr ihr
Mann ermöglichte aber auch immer mehr
eine Drang nach Eigenständigkeit und
Freiheit entwickelte und die diese
einengungsversuche immer mehr dazu
trieben ausbrechen zu wollen also eine
natürliche Gegenreaktion
tja und die Probleme haben sich dann
offenbar so weit verstärkt bis sie
schließlich den heftigen Streit und
unter Alkohol eskaliert sind es gibt
natürlich keine Rechtfertigung dafür was
sie mit ihrem Mann gemacht hat ja und
ich finde das ist halt auch dieser
typische Fall das gerade bei solchen
Sachen da ist es schwierig zu sagen wer
ist schuldig wäre es unschuldig weil
beide haben dazu beigetragen dass diese
Situation entstanden ist trotz allem hat
sie ihn umgebracht sie hat sein Leben
genommen und mit dieser Schuld muss sie
leben egal was sie dahin geführt hat man
fragt sich wieso es ihr nicht gelungen
ist nach dem Studium und auch mit ihrer
Tätigkeit als Ärztin wieso ist es ja
nicht gelungen sich von dieser Beziehung
zu lösen sie hätte doch auf jeden Fall
selbstständig sein können finanzielle
Mittler hätte sie sicherlich zur
Verfügung gehabt vielleicht hatte sie
das Gefühl dass sie irgendwas schuldig
ist weil ich meine hat sie ja sozusagen
wirklich rausgeholt auch von den ganzen
Drogen wegbekommen ja dass sie sich da
verpflichtet gefühlt haben
diese Stabilität gegeben die sie nie im
Leben hatte und trennungen sind nie
leicht ich glaube das können wir beide
irgendwie nachvollziehen ich glaube wenn
da halt eben so viel so viel mehr noch
dranhängt ist das noch mal ein step der
schwieriger ist was ich halt wirklich
tragisch finde dass sie diese harte
Vergangenheit hat und sich da
selbstständig rausgearbeitet hat und
eigentlich so ein tolles Leben vor sich
hatte und das wirklich durch diese Tat
Futures und das tut mir für Sie leid das
ist natürlich richtig aber man sieht
halt einerseits hat er ihr geholfen aus
dieser Situation rauszukommen
andererseits war er aber auch der Grund
dafür sicherlich einer der Gründe dafür
dass es halt dann zum Schluss zu
eskaliert ist ne das
sind so zwei Wege die sich offenbar
gegenseitig bedingt haben das eine ins
Positive laufende und das andere was
dann halt dazu geführt hat dass trotz
dieser ganzen positiven Dinge die da
passiert sind es dann doch irgendwann
eskaliert ist ja so ein tragisches Ende
nimmt und so ein tragisches Ende nimmt
und damit sind wir am Ende der heutigen
Episode angelangt wir danken euch fürs
zuhören und freuen uns wenn auch beim
nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei seid euer
Mirko und eure Toni das Skript ist von
Stefan nicht und er lässt euch auch noch
ausrichten dass ihr die beiden Artikel
aus Bild am Sonntag und Spiegel auch als
links in den Schauen ausfindet Aufnahme
und
schnittproduktion durch weight watch
Studios München bis zum nächsten Mal